[Music]
good
morning good afternoon good evening
wherever you are tuning in from we're so
excited to see you all here at our
your journey now i know from diverse
leaders event where we're going to hear
from a group of really really awesome
panelists a group of alums of the gsb my
name is jessica chung i'm an admissions
officer at the stanford graduate school
of business and i'm just really really
grateful that you are spending a little
bit of your day with us today
so i want to start by going over what
today's event will look like
we'll start with a brief introduction to
our community we're going to introduce
our panelists i have a few prepared
questions for them
just to get us warmed up and in the
meantime please submit your own
questions in the q a box you can feel
free to get a little practice in that q
a box and let us know
your name and where you're tuning in
from we always love seeing who's in the
zoom room with us
and then we'll turn to your questions in
the q a box you can also use the up
voting feature
if you see somebody has submitted a
question that really resonates with you
and that way we can try to address some
of the most pressing questions for the
group overall we're going to spend about
55 minutes together with the goal of
introducing you all to our gsb community
to
leaders who have come from our community
and represent all different experiences
and backgrounds
i'm going to take a look in the q a box
just because i am curious about who's in
the zoom room with us today
hello frank from providence rhode island
paula from columbia nicole from miami
mike from california hello gwen from
atlanta pooja from san francisco
nate from florida
gray from
spain
stacy from canada
nana from malaysia
wow it's so good to see you all and it's
awesome because in some ways this is
like a it's like a microcosm of what
it's like to be at the gsb where our
community really comes from all over the
country and all over the world so this
is very very exciting for us to see
where you all are tuning in from today
so a little bit about our community and
then i think you'll get a much
uh deeper sense of what our community is
like over the course of today's panel
our community includes over 30 000
alumni who are all over the country and
all over the world we have 60
volunteer-led regional chapters of
alumni around the world so it's truly a
community for life and on our campus we
have a variety of student organizations
women's programs diversity programs
there are many many different ways to
engage on our community both as a
student and as an alum
next i would like to turn it over to our
panelists to introduce themselves
going in alphabetical order
uh adriana you want to kick us off
sure hi everyone uh really happy to be
here i'm adriana piana i am class of
2012.
my my background is in undergrad i went
to nyu i have a double major in
psychology and sociology i worked at
pepsico before pepsico in mexico before
the the gsb
after the gsb like now i'm in tech and
i'm working for facebook but i've had a
journey of
like i did management consulting fintech
and now i'm in advertising so really
happy to be here
awesome thank you
alejandro
would you like to introduce yourself
everyone i'm alejandra aguirre class of
2019 uh so my background i studied
mechanical engineering at mit
uh spent a few years after undergrad in
boston worked at liberty mutual
insurance doing a data analytics work
uh when i was looking for
roles at gsp i was focused on startup
recruiting so i ended up actually using
the
gsb alumni network to land an internship
and my first role out of
gsp and now i'm currently working at an
early stage startup called work while uh
that is building a labor marketplace to
help hourly workers find jobs
awesome thank you
and jessica
and i'm jessica uh alejandro's classmate
um i went to howard for undergrad and
before the gsb i worked in private
equity and then um
in the food
space and then after the gsb i actually
went into venture and now i'm back in
private equity so i've also covered a
quite a realm of different
industries and ended up starting my own
private equity firm which is the century
partners
thank you all so much um one of our
panelists has not yet joined us which is
totally fine hopefully she'll be able to
join us later in the session
um before we dive into
the session i do want to note that this
is hopefully just one stop along your
journey
you can continue your journey if you
haven't already at mystanford.mba where
you can create a personalized dashboard
to keep track of your application browse
different parts of student life and
academic life at the gsb
and learn more about our events and stay
in touch with us
so with that i'm going to stop screen
share
and i do have a few prepared questions
for our panelists um as i said for our
attendees please feel free to submit
your questions in the q a box we love to
hear what you want to learn about today
um so my first question for our
panelists is why did you decide to
pursue an mba and why did you decide to
pursue an mba at stanford specifically
i can go first um
i think
the reasons why i wanted to pursue is
different that one happened later so
i
i was in mexico i studied in the us came
back to mexico and i was a psychology
major working on business process for
engineering
and so what i thought i needed or why i
thought i needed an mba is i had
fundamental gaps around business
um
and i think
going into it what i learned was it was
a lot more about a journey of personal
and professional transformation would be
very focused on personal transformation
and how i can be a better leader what
are the tools that you can actually use
um
as you grow and mature into
organizations and um
and what was the second question sorry
why a stanford mba and why stanford
because of that
part um i i was really keen
i had a really strong psychology
background and i was really keen on
human development and now i think with
design thinking and touchy feely like
it's become a lot more popular across
other schools but at that time it was
explicitly at stanford and i think it's
the best place uh
honestly to learn about that and that
stanford is a place where
vulnerability is expected
and that's really uncomfortable and i am
just really glad i i went to the gsp
and it was a
hugely transformational process for me
absolutely and for i think a lot of our
audience members might be familiar with
interpersonal dynamics which our alums
often call touchy-feely but um can you
say a little bit about what what that
class is yeah so it's a class where you
understand how your actions and
your words can impact the other person
and how to make sure you create deep
connections actually there's a new book
that's highly recommended um
it's
connecting you're going to know the name
better than me but i read it uh on carl
roman had the book like i i can just go
like personally i
i'm i'm part of the lgbt community i was
not out it was a time when mexico was
very complicated and through the gsb i
gained the security and the safety among
my classmates to actually come out and
that i think that's a process of
transformation that was really critical
and accepting myself as a true and
authentic leader and that i have carried
through my career
awesome thanks for sharing that with us
the ymba piece for me was connected to
realizing
that the growth of my career was not
based on just hard work but also
networks so it was when i looked at the
opportunity to do an mba i could not do
an mba and work really hard at finding
other connections and connections
outside of like my industry and
where i was in new york or i could use
an mba as like a catalyst for growth to
meet people that i never would have like
met and have been very difficult to try
to arrange like an international cohort
cross industry
cross country of people and so i
recognize that as having a lot of value
after a couple of years outside of work
um and i would say like
i mean
hopefully it's not surprising uh my
stanford mba delivered on that maybe 100
fold i think i was a little bit
maybe pessimistic isn't the word but
realistic about what the mba can give me
everyone's like it's gonna be a
life-changing experience and you're
gonna you know come out of it like
some supercharged person so i was just a
little bit realistic about what it could
mean for me but um in reality i would
say that my
and you don't really call it a network
it's you know your friends like people
that you know people that care about you
and not just inside outside of my class
but my class professors like other
people who are just randomly you know
contacted uh as a result of the
experience uh is truly just like so
meaningful to like where i am today
um and why i chose stanford was really
it's kind of really cheesy but it's
really in the dna of what it means and
it's just like you know clearly stated
in the uh byline of change lives changed
organizations changed the world and just
like an intent across my classmates um
and intent across a broader gsb
community i think to
um think substantively about the world
that we want to create and that we want
to see and not to say that everyone
agrees on what that looks like but we
all agree that there has to be like
change and we have to put in the work to
make a better like world for like not
only us for future generations so i felt
like that really underpinned uh what
people thought about or or how they
moved through the world and i really
appreciated that and so i chose stanford
even though i applied to seven
or eight schools
yeah so the the why mba for me is i
think i a couple years after undergrad i
was gonna hit like a fork in the road of
like what i what it was that i thought i
wanted to pursue uh i was in a data
analyst position so basically i was
either gonna go do like a data science
program a phd in stats or
do like an mba my
boss and mentor at the time was a
business school grad and so that's when
i started to kind of understand what
could come from that type of skill set
like what you can develop there i think
personally i had always been
more focused heads down on like the
technical work and not really
considering kind of the network the
power of like relationships within
business context so so that's i think
something that was appealing for me and
honestly even more than that was the
like optionality of like having two
years to explore and learn a lot about
like what actually
you know excites me which honestly like
was the biggest value of the gsp or just
an mba in general
um
and the why stanford specifically i
think there's probably three specific
things that come to mind so one is
wanting to dive into like startup
ecosystem uh i'd come from working at
two very very large companies uh prior
to the gsb so
startup kind of ecosystem community was
very foreign to me i didn't i didn't
really know anything about it so i
wanted to like basically dive head first
into that
uh the second was kind of like the whole
touchy-feely culture of the gsb not just
the class but just the idea that the
what that class represents is kind of
embedded into lots of other aspects of
the gsp
and i got that from like speaking to
alums
students and like admissions officers at
the time when i was searching for they
made it very clear that this was an
opportunity to develop personally not
just professionally which
um honestly ended up being like the the
reason why i decided to go to stanford
and the final choice is that i'm from
los angeles and i was tired of being on
the east coast i wanted to come back to
california
awesome thank you all for sharing those
reflections um i feel like each of you
touched on
sort of the distinctive
gsb community in different ways and the
this like shared culture of
vulnerability authenticity
and
um
we sort of call it principled leadership
like people-centric leadership
are there any
when you think back on your time at the
gsb are there any favorite memories or
favorite moments
that you feel really capture the
essence of the gsb community in gsb
family for you
well the highlight which is
[Music]
what most people get to experience once
you
get accepted or come for the weekend is
like is talk and they might do this at
other at other opportunities or other
junctures but i think that there's not
one particular talk but it's over
every week where people are sharing
their story and being very vulnerable
and open about um whatever it is it
doesn't have to be some kind of crazy um
overcome some huge mountain type of
story but it's really that ethos of like
who they are and like what matters to
them um i always think of it as an
extension of like the what matters most
to you and why
um question
that is traditionally what has been one
of the essays i don't know if it's an
essay anymore but anyway it
is application essay questions and so
it's great to get a window into people
and i think what comes out of that is
the vulnerability piece that we
mentioned it's the connection to people
um and realizing that everyone you know
as is their own little iceberg there's
just so much like underneath that you
don't traditionally get to see but it's
really cool to break that down and
people that you're close to people that
you don't really know just getting to
share that um common knowledge and
experience and be able to distill that
and i think therefore understand just
people in humanity better taking home
those stories and remembering them is
definitely one of the
big moments that i
um really cherish and still remember
many of those talks
i think of course for me giving my talk
and that's when i came out was it was a
big moment and i did it in a trip so
that's the other thing i'm going to
mention i was very focused on social
innovation so i and the gsb uh has a
mandatory
trip well i don't know what's called it
but i'm on the third trip abroad uh it
can be their business trip or a social
focus trip and i actually took four
so i went to india that's in a mini talk
where where i came out to my friends i
went to india on healthcare south africa
and education
kenya on social entrepreneurship and
then i did a nonprofit trip non-official
to
burundi randa and uganda and i think
those trips are just amazing the people
you get to have conversations with the
expansion of a global perspective and
the friendships that you develop from
those trip is just amazing
uh yeah i'll kind of emphasize the talk
bit as well um definitely like hearing
other people's stories but then going
through the process of like the
reflection that was kind of like a
repeat of the what matters most to you
and why reflection process it was just
doubling down and doing it a bit more at
least that was the case for me
um
yeah and i think going through
i spent the first like year or so like
not kind of
uh
i would say sharing all aspects of like
my family background and like life etc
and so obviously like that's that's not
a great way to start out an experience
but i think the the talk
process kind of helped me open up more
and then it helped me realize that like
you know some of the reasons that i was
maybe holding back were not really
warranted and that it was uh like to my
benefit and others benefit to to be more
transparent about that
um you know related to that uh
my second year myself and a couple of my
classmates we
uh helped start the first generation
low-income uh diversity group at the the
gsb and i mean i think the thing that i
took away from that is like how many
conversations i had with people about
those things not just in my class but in
the class below me as well
just like learning things about others
that otherwise you know
i would not have learned if i had not
like put myself out there in a certain
way so i think that that's something
that that i've taken away and like
continue to think about a lot and
obviously will certainly have like
continue to
have an impact in the way that i uh
interact with other people
yeah thank you so much for sharing that
and i i feel like you bring up
um
something that i'm really curious to
learn more about is how
how did your gsb experience
impact the way you think about the role
of identity and diversity and leadership
i mean this panel is all about diverse
leaders and i'm curious
how your perspectives on that evolved
because of your gsb experience
i could start i
i mean for me it changed me completely
and i think it took me a while to find
an organization to work for where my
values were aligned in the way i
i was
i learned to be and i learned to
be myself at the gsb so it took me a
while to get to a place like facebook i
was interim country director for
facebook mexico um and i was interim
country director for when kobe hit so i
was in charge of managing the corporate
crisis
and what we saw and the role that i had
to take as a leader was one of
authenticity and vulnerability
we did not have the answers and and
i was actually in charge of helping a
lot of mexico ceos and a lot of our
clients and advertisers walk through
that journey of showing up authentically
showing up with vulnerability we had i
mean and we still do have people
struggling with health mental health
issues and whatnot and
yes we are driving for performance but
caring of the individual as a whole has
been paramount to all of the efforts
that we've been doing and that i learned
at the gsp like i couldn't have done
that without the tools that i that i
learned of the gsb
i think the
so i think prior to going to attendance
to gsb i think my identity as like being
latino being like first gen was not
really top of mind honestly it took a
back seat to a lot of other things for
most of like undergrad and my
professional career before the mba
but arriving at
stanford and i think
you know and
you'd see this at in any kind of top
business school just seeing that
diversity isn't really where it ought to
be
i think that kind of helped me
[Music]
figure out i realized like how important
that was to me and how much time i
personally wanted to dedicate to those
issues like that so i don't know
specifically how it's influenced kind of
like my own personal like leadership
style but it certainly has influenced uh
what i choose to invest my time in and
what it is that i feel like strong
conviction around uh making sure that i
like raise my voice in
so i mean in addition to the the first
general income stuff i was co-present
for the hispanic business student
association while at stanford uh but i
also kind of the the idea of like
helping underserved communities was
always like kind of a common theme in my
own personal career search and i've been
pretty fortunate that i've been able to
land somewhere where i feel like that my
job is consistent with those values even
though i am working at a dc backed
startup and that's i think it's pretty
rare that someone can say that so
i don't know i i think that it's it's
the perspective i got from stanford
through that kind of fueled my career
search but also kind of the way i look
at the world and you know how i how i
want to operate within it
uh 100 on that alejandra like i couldn't
have said that even better trying to
think of like an eloquent way to like
state that but i think my experience
with the gsb was one that magnified my
ability to realize like oh my gosh like
i'm a black woman and like there's so
much here that we have to continue to
press for and work for toward if like we
want to if i want to see
like more of me at this school
in society and i'm using more of me but
i mean just like professional women
professional black people like at the
table um and i have like a
strong positioning in doing that um and
so that was that's what really i think
kind of changed my catalyst of my career
was thinking about oh the opportunity as
a capital allocator to be able to
uh pour money into underserved
communities as a way of being able to
uh back uh underserved individuals and
that for that that that being a catalyst
uh into the trickle-down effect of who
is employed and who is making money and
so just really change my mindset in
terms of like my positioning and the
work that i want to do and like how i
want to serve
communities and so now in my work i'm
specifically focused on
how can i invest
in thinking about diversity as a value
enhancer so not just in um not a
concessionary return type of thing but
to say like diversity the thing that's
here to stay and i think that there's a
real value in that and so how do i uh
back diverse owned companies how do i
put diverse people into leadership
positions and governance positions um
and then think about the underlying
societies that they're they're serving
so um yeah it was a huge
push and change of direction for me
awesome thank you all for sharing those
reflections and
um i feel like you all
bring up something that is
um that i want to acknowledge you know
we're we're not a perfect institution we
we have work to do when it comes to
diversity and to representation
and to inclusion
um we're not perfect and that's
something that i and i think many of my
colleagues would transparently say
one thing that i have admired during my
time at stanford so far is that there's
i think institutionally a will to change
and a responsiveness to students
for example
last summer as a response to the
uprisings against
murders of black folks by police forces
stanford gsb launched the action plan
for racial equity and it's something
that we're
trying to hold ourselves accountable to
in the admissions office we
are
building out partnerships with
organizations that
support folks from underrepresented or
historically excluded backgrounds
such as forte and
management leadership for tomorrow so
we're not a perfect institution by any
means
but we are
working
to
be better and that's something that that
i do admire about our community and our
institution um and i want to thank our
panelists for for their transparency
around that because
i think
ultimately the purpose of these panels
is to to tell the truth and study at the
gsb so i appreciate that from you all as
well
so i'm turning to our q a box
um
and there are a couple questions
i'm going to see if i can kind of group
them
well there are a couple questions about
sort of transitions and the ways that
the gsb might have
changed you or changed your path um so
for example
charles asks how has your what matters
most changed during and after stanford
if at all
which i think is such an interesting
question
so i can say that again how has your
what matters most
changed during and after stanford if at
all
it's a constant for me i think i just
mostly wrote about like my family and
the legacy um i feel like i'm creating
and have the like
opportunity
or
to take part of but yeah it's like what
it boils down to is like my family and
how much they like mean to me and how
much it matters and so
that's a constant it's like my number
one like like most important thing value
or whatever so hopefully that won't
change
uh yeah my what matters most to me and
why
uh when i wrote my essay was uh
basically being a role model to younger
generation and underserved communities
um when i wrote that my head in mind
based like my nephews like other kids
growing up in my in my neighborhood i
don't think it's changed too much i
think the way that i would kind of
reframe it is like being a change agent
to support those individuals now um i
think that's more top of mind now than
it was before the gsb
and i think
i mean you're listening to alejandra and
jessica if you really write it right
it doesn't change right and
more than changing for me it's been a
north star when i
left the gsb i joined consulting in the
bay area and when i read it i i was
miserable in the role uh
and it took me like one night of reading
it and knowing that i needed to
transition that all of the things that i
had built and what i wanted to do and
what was my mission was not getting
fulfilled there and so that's the reason
why i decided to go back to mexico and
then look for opportunities where i
could have the impact i was wanting to
have which was part of uh my whole what
matters most to uh so i think it's more
of a north star and it might change in
tones and whatever but it is if it's
written correctly it should not change
i love that and i i feel like i hear
that so often from our students and from
our from our alums about going through
the application process that often the
very first step is
reflecting going through that process of
introspection to really really figure
out
where you are where you want to go with
your career what matters most to you and
why
i feel like you capture that really
really perfectly
sort of on the
uh i think if what matters most cny is
on the personal side on the more
professional side we do have a couple
questions too about
career pivots um
nate asks nate says i noticed adriana
and alejandra transitioned into the tech
industry could you share a specific
experience like a class club internship
et cetera at stanford that had the
largest impact to prepare you for your
current roles
so i think that's a question that all of
you could respond to what's
a
class club internship that
had the largest impact on you and
prepared you for your current role um
especially if you were pivoting which i
believe actually all three of you were
pivoting into into different industries
um
so yeah we'll start there
i can start
uh so
for me uh when i was coming into the gsp
i had kind of this idea that i wanted to
work in autonomous vehicle technology
that was largely informed by coming from
the insurance industry and just wanting
some way of transitioning into tech
that eventually kind of evolved and
turned into
labor marketplaces for underserved
communities
specifically low-wage workers i think
the things the specific classes that
helped me get there it wasn't like a
linear path but they helped me get there
was one was startup garage which i'm
sure many viewers are familiar with
with like kind of the content it's on
the stanford website
and the other was data and decisions
which is pretty random i don't think
many people would attribute any kind of
like career pin from that class but i
did get to work on a project with a
startup that was a marketplace and that
was the very first time i'd ever kind of
had first exposure with that type of
business model and that kind of got me
really excited and i ended up wanting to
to go in that direction
i could talk a little bit about mine i
ended up in tech by accident um my
career has not been as planned as other
other people's but but i think
when you think about like
and i'll talk about international and
and like i've worked in the us i worked
in mexico and i'm back in the u.s now
and i think that gives you also a very
different perspective so i
when i
moved back to mexico what i wanted to do
is maximize impact and working to
generate economic empowerment in in the
country and so
tech was
an easy choice in that regard because
when i was offered the job at paypal it
was to manage smbs and empowering
digital payments for smbc and you can
see the chain of impact so i didn't join
because it was tech i joined because it
was the most scalable way to have to
have impact and i joined in a commercial
function
where
it is if particularly for those who want
to do tech abroad mostly
outside of london switzerland uh tel
aviv and maybe a little bit in singapore
most of the tech roles tend to be
uh commercial and so you develop a
really strong commercial acumen
and so that's coming back to the us i'm
more focused on learning about product
which i haven't learned
in my career but expanding that product
component to my skill set that is mostly
commercial and i mean the partnerships
team i think classes specifically it's
hard i mean of course you're going to
have to use data and whatnot but for me
there's two critical classes one is and
i don't know if they still exist i'm i'm
out almost 10 years now it's uh cat
critical analytical thinking the biggest
gap we see in talent particularly in
emerging markets is critical analytical
thinking when it comes to tech
data is now pervasive and it's how you
use the data how you question and how do
you do hypotheses and hypothesis testing
that that's really important and the
other one is your spirit your petersons
managing growing enterprises that is i
use it every day it's like as a people
leader and as a people manager the cases
that you review and the skillsets that
you develop on on people literally
there's not a day where i don't put some
of that in practice
yeah now this is taking on a couple of
different things i would say um two
things in terms of like career switching
one thing that was really catalytic for
me and maybe it is inherent in my
approach is like it's really the people
when i came to gsb i explore a lot of
different careers by just talking to
people just like
messaging i would have this goal and
it's a very me very planner type thing
but like reach out to like three people
every week um related to like whatever i
was pursuing and while i was at the gsb
i explored a lot of like different ideas
about things that i would enjoy and so
it like focused on cornering that like
industry or some industry to learn about
it um so that was one way and actually
what became a catalyst for my career was
one of my professors um just taking an
interest in me but i took an interest
first in this professor like i was very
forthcoming about building relationships
not only with like the
um
my peers but also like the faculty and
professors and so um one of the
professors was very catalytic and like
helping me to like think through um
and get some exposure in in venture
which led me to uh working in andreessen
horowitz after business school or
actually while in business school and
after business school um and
i would say on the kind of like classes
that were formative um would definitely
double click on managing growing
enterprises i took it with graham weaver
and it was definitely something i like
go back and think about and actually
reference um some of the materials there
uh negotiations class was very like
helpful it's a
mended class but just really helpful in
thinking about
doing better at negotiating and actually
negotiating i never negotiated for my
career prior to
the gsb
and i think it's especially a downfall
of diverse people especially
people of color and women
there was another class acting with
power um
specifically playing up or playing down
certain elements to
um just do a better job at like showing
up we can't all show up the same way
every day to to achieve our goals and
just so how do we think about our
approach and use some kind of acting
techniques
in which to do it and i could probably
um
rattle on but those are just a couple
that really stood out for me
awesome thank you all so much for those
insights
um
let me see
rashmi asked a question that i that i'm
curious about as well rashmi asked what
surprised you the most about the gsb
once you started the program
and i'm also curious were there any
not just surprises but any
preconceptions you had about the gsb or
myths that were
debunked or confirmed
once you arrived on campus
i'd say the mba itself and actually
can't speak to other experiences but um
someone told me in my um internship
before the gsb that like they remember
specifically having a meeting with them
and they're like your experience is
gonna go like this like this like this
and i was like okay i really don't know
what that means like it's you're going
to classes like i've been to undergrad
like you know i've studied before so i'm
not really sure what to like this like
this like this is but it was actually
a perfect um
description of like i think what i
experienced um
just being in a place um taking yourself
away from
generally close like family and friends
and being a different environment um
i think where your goal is to to grow is
very difficult um and just hard
sometimes which like led to like
multiple like crying sessions and it was
never um
necessarily anything dire but i think
that personal growth really does um
take some time and and take some
you know energy like ups and downs to
kind of get there and i think that that
was probably
um one of the most like catalyst things
i whenever any experience i've
experienced like substantive challenge
i've always come out of it and been a
much better person and so
i was definitely
surprised by that because i thought i
would like grow and be academically
smarter and come out with like more
friends but in think about actually the
journey being something that would
be sometimes arduous
for me i think
there's so many things that surprise you
and completely agree with with jessica
but
then again being very sensitive to the
context the amount of traveling um when
when you're not from north america
you think you're global like you think
like oh we're not like north
america-centric i have a global
perspective and i really did not have a
global perspective like the world really
opened up for me in that way and the
cultures that i that i was able to to
know and experience and just through
classmates and traveling i think it was
an
amazing experience on the negative side
and speaking on on the nature of the gsb
and how we work on changing things
i
had barely come out in mexico and i was
like i'm coming to the bay area
this is like rainbow town and lo and
behold when i joined i was
there was only one lesbian in the two
classes um
openly
and so i was in shock i just couldn't
believe that and we did a lot of work on
this and i think uh the g is that's
where you see the gsb's commitment on
how how to do that and how to make sure
we and it was also a different type
because if you look back at the classes
now i think there's like 10. but it's
how you get people to be comfortable
with who they are as as they progress i
think also being
it's not the same like being a woman
you're already a minority being a
lesbian like intersectionality matters
and that's what we saw and that's what
we analyzed and how we worked towards
being more pressing out for mba like
having more female presence because he
was mostly a male presence and um i know
there was a lot of investment in that
area but that was something that i was i
was very shocked when when i got there
coming from mexico particularly
uh yeah for me i think um on the travel
piece like obviously i'd heard from like
friends and like what the travel culture
was like at most mba programs um it was
definitely ended up being a lot more
than i anticipated and before the gsb
i'd been to like two countries outside
of
uh the us and by the end of it i've been
to 13. so like obviously it's like you
know that's something that i chose to
take a lot like take advantage of so i
think that's definitely a positive the
the thing that i think i
didn't see coming and that i need to
adjust to is kind of like what jessica
was describing around like the the waves
of just things hitting you and there's
just a lot of momentum as soon as you
arrive on campus that if you're not
taking the time to like stop and be
intentional about which way kind of
you're pointing you can easily get swept
up in whatever is kind of happening on
campus right like whether that be like
social events or or the you know outings
traveling or what uh the extracurricular
activities that seem the most fun right
i i think there's there were definitely
plenty of times where i had to like stop
and reflect kind of similar to what i
the reflection i had done before gsp
just to make sure that i was kind of
doing the things that were in line with
what i wanted to achieve long term
and i thought i was good at time
management but i realized i needed to
get better while i was at school in
school
thank you all for those responses i'm
curious
um you all mentioned different sort of
challenges that you encountered at the
ghs
i'm wondering how did you
create challenges what were the
resources or support systems that you
drew upon to weather those challenges
i mean i think there's a myriad of
resources so so for me i joined the
diversity board
um
and what's great to see there and
listening both to alex and jessica is
how that evolves right because people
are saying like are you were you
addressing the racial
injustice issue well
it wasn't
in a stage where we were aware we were
addressing the issues that were current
at that time and there were pressing
issues and so you can see how
having that active leadership and having
a body that can support that is so
meaningful and so important for for um
transformation not only of us but of uh
the school culture and the school
principles and whatnot um
i think classmates like
it takes a while like i'm i've been out
for 10 years almost but it takes a while
for people to start
opening up about how they're struggling
but once they do it's like it's like
collective catharsis and so you have a
lot of support groups and you also have
like i don't know i was a they call us a
poet when you're not from a quant
background and i remember we had the
death poet society in winter quarter
which also changed because all of the
quantum classes were in one quarter and
it was wink third quarter uh but we all
got together we had extra classes by tas
even the professors were engaged to make
sure that we felt supported as we've uh
navigated those academic challenges so i
think for everything they're like the
gsb has already it's just amazing like
there's there's a resource or
you can get funding or there's like
friends anything it's it's
multi-dimensional how you get support as
you're facing these challenges
so many resources like is all i can say
same thing as adriana like i mean just
broadly i'll just like talk about the
resources not necessarily related to
those challenges but like like i use a
communication coach or communications
coach i was there i went to the career
resource center i don't know how many
times just like chatting with the people
there about opportunities and where i
saw myself as i was exploring
opportunities um
there's like our academic um
advisor for our section
who like i loved and saw a couple of
times
um
and then there's just like resources
that are just outside of the gsb beyond
the people that are there which i think
um adriana already mentioned like your
peers um oh actually there's tutoring um
i
definitely uh needed a tutor for some of
the classes um and so i was like peer
tutors so that was super helpful um
and then just outside the gsb a number
of people um in my class are very open
about seeing some of the
um
some of the why am i losing the my train
of thought but um basically seeing some
of the facilitators related to like
psychological or any type of like mental
health care things there's like a great
resource like belong to that and there's
like no stigma attached to it i feel
like almost half the people i know went
to that um center and i forget the name
of it um and there's just like resources
like abound on i agree on whatever you
need there's that and then uh the second
year i found like a meditation center on
campus i would go to the meditation
center and just like take the time to
like breathe so anyway there's like
there's more resources than you'll have
the opportunity to use
yeah i would agree with definitely the
career
uh support i think that was like pretty
important for me since i was doing like
startup recruiting there was no kind of
structured way of recruiting for that
and kind of related to that i think like
the alumni network was huge um i i got
two internships during while i was at
gsp one over the summer and then one
during second year both were through
alumni network connects uh from like
cold outreach and like basically
getting the ball moving that way so
those are huge
and i would also agree with jessica on
the stanford-wide resources when it
comes like mental health i personally
took advantage of like the therapy and
mental health services that were offered
there and you know that was made a big
difference for me uh while i was going
through the business through business
school program um and again like i know
many of my peers uh took advantage of
those resources as well and uh they were
also folks that were very forthcoming
with uh that and yeah there definitely
is no stigma there's
a lot of acceptance around like you know
you gotta do what you gotta do take care
of yourself and i think people are
openly kind of willing there to to be
supportive of you or whatever that means
appreciate all of those insights
there's a great question from
mike sauce
or mike
who asks what sets the gsb apart from
other schools with regards to diversity
and inclusion
i'll give you a second to think about
that and repeat the question what sets
the gsb apart from other schools or
what's distinctive about the gsb with
respect to
diversity and inclusion
i think you're we're all struggling a
bit because it's like hard to say
because we didn't go to those schools
and we're super cognizant of the fact
that like we we didn't so it's like it
would only be by what other people have
told me um
i would say what i think is distinctive
is what i start off by saying which is
like a real intent to
do things differently and change and and
to listen and be like open and honest
and have real conversations with one
another that could happen on other
places i don't know but i think it's
like what um underlies the culture of
stanford that creates these um true
conversations where we can be real with
one another about like
this made me feel this way and also just
the tools we're actually given the tools
through interpersonal dynamics you know
i.e touchy feely to be able to have real
conversations um to lean into what's
uncomfortable and to
um yeah just dig into what would
generally be taboo conversation so i
would i would say that of the experience
but yeah i can't holistically speak to
what other universities are doing or
what it's like just that the culture of
the gsb is what resonates most for me
yeah for me similar i
didn't go to other schools but i could
tell you that
the spirit and that fight uh for making
the world a better place continues so
i'm class of 2012 and uh with all the
social unrest in the in the u.s last
year my class got together and we
actually have not only a whatsapp
working group where we share resources
and
i'm
sad laurie was not here because was part
of that world but basically we one we
have a lot of types of people which is
amazing because then
we're uh we get together every quarter
since um it's been like a year and a
half now and we discuss what are the
practices that we're establishing in our
own companies how we can share those to
make sure that we create a better and
more inclusive place in where we're
working and that just talks about the
spirit of the gsb and the people who are
the gsb and people who really just have
a mindset of how do we create a better
and more inclusive place for everyone
and i'll just reiterate what jessica
said like i have no idea what other
programs are like i i
i assume they're like similar but i
think what what i observed at the gsp
from
being there from like beginning my first
year where i was kind of plugged into
diversity initiatives being uh on like
hbsa board like i was very kind of
plugged in and aware of like what the
broader administration was doing and you
know
it's not perfect uh but what i have seen
is like a lot of like progress and a lot
of like willingness to like understand
what it is that students need what and
alumni need uh in order to like improve
that so i think most recently the gsp
was uh working through like a racial
equity task force uh that i participated
in that basically brought together
alumni
uh from across many different
generations to talk about a lot of these
issues that were top of mind for
students
and alums and the rest of our community
and
um basically with the intention of
figuring out what actions the gsb needed
to take to my knowledge i haven't heard
of other programs
doing that or having similar initiatives
so i think to me that that kind of
speaks volumes of what the gsp is
willing to do at least in terms of
listening to start considering kind of
plans for for improving
diversity awesome thank you all for
those those insights um
i feel like you've each touched on
the
sort of mission orientation of stanford
gsb and of the community and we have a
few questions about
social innovation opportunities and
resources at the gsb or about
or about opportunities and support for
pursuing careers that are maybe a little
bit quote unquote off the off the beaten
path um that might be in
social innovation or non-profit or
education or
that
um that explore or fulfill some of those
goals around serving underrepresented or
under-resourced communities
could you all speak a little bit to
opportunities resources in social
innovation or social impact
at the gsb
i didn't do a good job at taking
advantage of all the resources but i
think like my approach to social impact
was just like it should just be a part
of the dna so i ended up taking away a
certificate because i took so many
classes on social impact because they're
just like that interesting to me that
was never the goal um
there are many different resources like
there that are focused on impact
investing there's
a social innovation club
you'll find a lot of those different
like interests like fulfilled a lot of
people that share
those interests on campus just through
kind of formal aggregating bodies
and i'd say if you want to just do
something different stanford is a great
place to be even if you're i feel like
oh this is like a one of one thing i
always
initially came in thinking that i wanted
to do like a food start-up and in terms
of food and beverage there weren't a lot
of us represented
in that group but like i think therein
lies the opportunity
the alumni group is is so large and the
community is really large to be able to
fulfill that
so what i
what i advise is just doing what i said
earlier just making sure that you get
out there and start talking to people
and ask people like do you know someone
in this industry moreover um something i
advise to all the people that i talk to
that are headed to business school are
going soon is like what do you want your
brand to be when you arrive on campus
what's your like one-liner what do you
want to be known for because that's
going to stick with you and if people
know you as like the
woman who's interested in social
innovation in east africa those
opportunities will magnetize to you but
you need to be able to communicate
what
that is to people if that makes sense
and so if you say that a bunch of times
and you say that to your class of 400
you're going to get a lot of opportunity
because within the community people
their intent is to help and they're
going to want to see you be successful
so um
i would think about that wherever you go
wherever you end up just like what's
your tagline
and you know how do you start to kind of
magnetize those opportunities
yeah i also have the the certificate uh
one resource i have is the disco i took
a bunch of classes at the disco design
the famous i i remember the name the
famous one but then i also had a design
for education i had a bunch of classes
around different social issues but it
has been interesting for me 10 years out
with all of my friends who were
interested and all of us who were taking
the social innovation and social
impact classes is how our careers have
shifted and so some of us think of our
impact in a different way so the way i
think about it at facebook is we're
enabling connectivity we're enabling
opportunity i serve the svg segment
again uh in my new role and so
what we can do is different and then you
see so my friends who i know were in
impact investing before they went
full-on corporate and are now in a
corporate environment but in east africa
for example so it's taking different
ways and not necessarily doing the
for-profit mission-driven companies um
and that's i think how amazing it is on
on your
my perspective for social media which is
broadened by the resources and the
friendships that i formed and the
purview that i was able to shape at the
gsb
uh i actually didn't kind of pursue many
of the social innovation coursework i
think the the classes i ended up
choosing were more focused on i guess
like traditional like startup ecosystem
work but the one thing i will say that
is probably relevant to this is
uh while you're a student um you know
reaching out to folks outside of the gsp
network just like folks that are working
in an area that you're interested
whether it be like specific innovation
space social impact type role even if
they're not gsp affiliated while you're
at stanford kind of hearing from
students specifically gsb like business
school students it's actually really
you know you very likely get a response
so like use the time that while you're
in school to like reach out and like
network with those individuals that are
in your kind of career area of career
interest um because you'll you'll
actually learn to end up getting being
able to connect with a lot more folks
than than if you kind of wait until
after you're you're done with school
that's just my personal experience from
uh networking for for startups and other
related areas
so i know we are coming up on time um
for our attendees you'll see that we
have a poll we want to know how we're
doing um ultimately our events are all
about serving you so we want to know if
we're doing a good job and we take your
feedback very very seriously
um with our last minute
um
there is one last question and i'll ask
our panels to be to be brief in their
responses if they could
but i love this question there's a
question asking when you think back
about your experience at stanford what
are you most grateful for
so this will be a lightning round what
are you most grateful for when you think
back about your experience at stanford
the people
that was one of them
yeah
that was a leia thank you
well thank you all so much for spending
a bit of your day with us and thank you
to our incredible panelists for sharing
sharing your stories and sharing your
experiences with us and with all of our
attendees tonight i hope you all have a
great rest of your day and if you have
any other questions please feel free to
get in touch with us we are here to
serve you and we are 100 in your corner
so thank you again to our attendees and
thank you so much again to our amazing
panelists have a good night
[Music]
you